[Music]
alright y'all I love emojis I love using
them but apparently there's like a
secret teen emoji language that's going
around and I have teenagers in my house
so I need to crack down I'm gonna figure
it out so people that are very mean
behind the scare of giving me a bunch of
emojis and I'm supposed to maybe
possibly know which I by know some I
probably won't know one it's fine it's
I'm okay with it so the first one is a
goat emoji I mean meet me up for you
meet me for yoga like goat yoga like I
don't know like or go you're goading
someone what's it mean greatest of all
time I probably have a goat next to my
name a lot I'm just like oh my god the
second one kind of looks like a butt but
I think it's a peach is it a bud does it
mean like like like oh nice nice peach
is that real it's a butt Oh cuz it looks
like a butt not a peach okay so three is
an avocado the pit still in it does that
make a difference I've got to go avocado
avocado I don't I don't know what what
is avocado mean what avocado is so great
it's kind of rude to avocados
I love guacamole with chips the next one
is a zipped face with what looks like a
family emoji so maybe like don't tell
your parents don't tell your parents
I'll look out for that one
a fox emoji I mean obviously that's been
nice to my name cuz I'm a box right if
somebody's a fox oh wait is it bad don't
put it by my name what does a fox mean
Oh sneaky sneaking out my kids can't do
that now with security as well good luck
a single red rose
mmm Casanova that's a little sexy right
is that what that means you're looking
for a sugar daddy my 18 year old
daughter better not be using any Rose is
it's kind of going back to the bachelor
something you get a rose
you get a rose um no okay the dark moon
emoji looking off to the side like they
think I'm sleeping but I'm still up
watching Netflix
that's what Savannah does are 18 year
old oh you're throwing shade since half
minutes a shade Oh like the next one is
an octopus really I mean I only have
like offensive non daytime TV answers
for this one what is an octopus what an
octopus means cuddles that's kind of
creepy but like all the tentacles I like
my thought better if I want to make
emojis I've now decided a slice of pizza
emoji you want pizza like I mean you
want to KITT get a bite grab a bite or
what's a pizza slice
what if somebody sends an emoji that's a
slice of pizza it means I love you
how why you just send the freaking heart
there's a heart emoji you know what a
heart means love you know what pizza
means caloric intake but it's worth it I
don't think I did very well at emojis
but I kind of feel like I'm smarter for
it I might be a little more educated cuz
I don't understand how some of those s
yeah and octopus should not mean cuddles
it's just really creepy or there's a lot
of people coming so many ARMs no no
maybe it's a party that's what octopus
it's not a party I'm into but some
people might be into I don't share I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this